le bateau de secours aux migrants louise
michel a été évacué dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
49 personnes jugées vulnérables ont été
transférés en priorité par les gardes
côtes italiens
les autres rescapés ont été déplacées à
bord du navire humanitaire al mansi
watch quatre au total ils étaient deux
cents dix-neuf naufragés à être secouru
par le louise michel navires
humanitaires financés par l'artiste
banksy sa première opération de
sauvetage s'était déroulée ce jeudi
une volontaire raconte le premier des
deux sauvetages
il était assez difficile de les trouver
car le temps était mauvais le vent
augmente et les vagues étaient très
fortes et il nous a fallu un certain
temps pour y arriver il s'est avéré que
c'était un bateau en caoutchouc très
surpeuplé environ 90 personnes sur le
bateau qui avait déjà passé quelques
jours en mer qui était donc épuisé
déshydraté certaines d'entre elles
avaient le mal de mer à cause des
conditions météorologiques et était en
hypothermie
le bateau se trouvait ce samedi dans une
zone de recherches et de secours de
malte le pays qui a contacté des garde
côtes italiens en raison de la
détérioration des conditions
météorologiques
le louise michel avait lui aussi lancé
plusieurs appels de détresse pointant du
doigt l'inaction de l'union européenne
voici les survivants dont vous vous
détournez l'union européenne après avoir
échappé à une horreur et une inhumanité
indicible ils ont besoin d'un lieu sûr
vous devez agir maintenant un décès est
à déplorer sur le bateau cette année
plus de 300 migrants auraient trouvé la
mort en méditerranée
un chiffre qui pourrait être beaucoup
plus élevé selon l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations
le bureau de médecins sans frontières au
pays-bas dénonce de son côté la
situation intenable des navires
humanitaires en méditerranée